escribe siete cuartos como un número
mixto seis siete cuartos es una fracción
impropia porque 7 es más grande que 4 y
bueno lo vamos a escribir como un número
mixto pero lo vamos a escribir de una
forma muy directa y ya después vamos a
ver cómo funciona la forma directa en la
que lo hacemos aunque entonces tenemos
por aquí siete y luego cuarto y si lo
queremos escribir como un número mixto
primero tenemos que tomar el siete y
dividirlo entre cuatro entonces cuatro
cabe una sola vez una sola vez en el 7
entonces nos queda ver 1 por 44 lo
restamos para obtener el residuo y el
residuo es 7 menos 4 3 entonces siete
cuartos es exactamente igual a un entero
está entero de aquí nada
es cuartos que puedes ver que esté
entero sale de este 1 por acá y por otro
lado este 3 sale del residuo por acá y
finalmente el 4 es el mismo denominador
que teníamos en la fracción ok
aquí lo que hicimos fue dividir a 7 que
es el numerador entre 4 para ver cuántos
enteros teníamos y resultó que tenemos
únicamente un entero pero que dejaba un
residuo de 3 a ver pero son muchas
líneas y vamos a borrarlas y además
cuando usamos notación de números mixtos
no tenemos que poner este más por acá y
podemos mover la fracción un poquito más
cerca y listo
ahí está nuestro número mixto que
representa a siete cuartos uno que es el
resultado de la división de 7 entre 4 3
que es el residuo de la división y 4 que
es el denominador de esta fracción ahora
entiendo perfectamente que sientas que
esto es como vudú pero no a ver vamos a
dibujar 494 para que todo quede muy
claro
a ver cómo tenemos aquí siete cuartos lo
que voy a hacer es dibujar esos siete
pedacitos de un cuarto de algún pastel
aunque entonces ponemos por aquí un
cuarto y ahora este pedacito de pastel
va a ser cuadrado entonces cómo vamos a
tener siete de estos pedacitos lo que
voy a hacer es copiar y pegar los siete
veces entonces ahí tenemos al segundo
pedacito que lo vamos a colocar aquí al
lado del primer pedacito y ahora
volvemos a pegar y lo colocamos por acá
entonces llevamos tres pedazos van por
el cuarto que vamos a colocar por aquí y
bueno esto ya se ve como un entero no
entonces el siguiente pedazo vamos a
colocarlo más para acá y llamamos en el
sexto pedazo entonces nada más nos falta
uno
qué es el séptimo pedazo aunque ya
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 cuartos estamos de
acuerdo bueno por aquí tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro pedazos cuatro
cuartos y por acá tenemos uno dos tres
cuartos tres cuartos entonces estos
siete cuartos los acabamos de dibujar y
colocar por acá de una forma muy
conveniente ahora déjame lo escribo por
aquí siete cuartos es igual a cuatro
cuartos más tres cuartos lo que hay de
hecho este siete cuartos lo podemos
escribir como cuatro más tres cuartos
pero bueno el truco aquí es que pusimos
a cuatro cuartos de un lado porque
cuatro cuartos son un entero acá
entonces aquí cuatro cuartos es igual a
uno que es este uno por acá y bueno nos
deja como residuo tres cuartos aquí
entonces básicamente cuando queremos
escribir una fracción impropia como un
número mixto buscamos la cantidad de
enteros
en esta fracción y escribimos a la
derecha la fracción que nos sobra y eso
es de lo que estábamos haciendo aquí
dividimos 7 entre 4 para ver cuántos
enteros hay en esa fracción entonces
déjame escribo esto
el resultado de 7 entre 4 es siempre
igual al número de enteros
pero que tiene la fracción y cuando lo
dibujamos por aquí pues nada más tenemos
que contar la cantidad de enteros que
formamos y aquí en esta fracción también
aparece cuántos enteros caben pero luego
no se nos tiene que olvidar el residuo y
bueno el residuo pues nos dice cuántos
pedacitos de un cuarto nos sobraron
entonces lo que nos queda es el residuo
pero dividido entre el denominador
aunque en esta fracción se ve aquí que
lo tenemos que dividir entre el
denominador y aquí en el dibujo se nota
pues porque lo que tenemos son tres
pedazos de un cuarto entonces el número
mixto es un entero un entero y tres
cuartos